This has nothing to do with the
righteous being investigated by God.
Regardless of your esqueological
position, this is clearly a judgment
upon the wicked and is yet another proof
that the first and second angel's
messages were not fulfilled in 1844 like
Ellen White and the SDA church claimed.
[Music]
Oh, what's up YouTube? As always,
welcome to the channel. So, today we're
continuing our series in examining the
gospel of Jesus Christ up and against
the gospel of 7th Day Adventism. If you
missed part one, I suggest checking that
out. The link is in the description box
down below. In part one, we honed in on
this phrase, the everlasting gospel that
the Adventist Church has borrowed from
Revelation 14:6 to brand their uniquely
packaged three angels messages gospel.
If you remember, we read a list of
doctrines that make up their gospel,
which include a number of distinctive
Adventist pillar doctrines. Today, we're
going to begin unpacking and looking at
what they call the first angel's
message. Quickly, if you like videos
like this, please be so kind as to smash
that like button, subscribe, and ring
the notification bell so you can be
notified when content like this is
uploaded. So, I want to read Revelation
14 6-7. Then, we'll begin examining how
the Adventist Church interprets and
applies this. It says, "Then I saw
another angel flying directly overhead
with an eternal gospel to proclaim to
those who dwell on earth, to every
nation and tribe and language and
people. And he said with a loud voice,
fear God and give him glory because the
hour of his judgment has come and
worship him who made heaven and earth,
the sea and the springs of water. So to
understand the avenous application of
this, you have to understand a little
bit about 7th advenist history. The
claim is that the first angel's message
was proclaimed in 1843 and 44 through
those who were heralding the false date
setting for the return of Christ that
William Miller was teaching. His
followers were called the Millerites.
Speaking of this, Ellen White said the
following.
I saw that the disappointment of those
who believed in the coming of the Lord
in 1844 was not equal to the
disappointment of the first disciples.
Prophecy was fulfilled in the first and
second angel's messages. They were given
at the right time and accomplish the
work which God designed to accomplish by
them. So prophecy of revelation 14 was
supposedly fulfilled in the proclamation
of the 1843 and 44 message. Remember
this. She expounds further in spiritual
gifts volume 1 on page 133 where she
writes, "I saw that God was in the
proclamation of the time in 1843. It was
his design to arouse the people and
bring them to a testing point where they
should decide. Thousands were led to
embrace the truth preached by William
Miller. The servants of God were raised
up in the spirit and power of Elijah to
proclaim the message. Those who preached
this solemn message, like John the
forerunner of Jesus, felt compelled to
lay the axe at the root of the tree and
call upon men to bring forth fruits meat
for repentance. Their testimony was
calculated to arouse and powerfully
affect the churches and manifest their
real character. And as they raised the
solemn warning to flee from the wrath to
come, many who were united with the
churches received the healing message.
They saw their backslidings and with
bitter tears of repentance and deep
agony of soul humbled themselves before
God. And as the spirit of God rested
upon them, they helped to sound the cry,
"Fear God and give glory to him, for the
hour of his judgment is come." So after
Christ failed to return as predicted in
1844, William Miller admitted he was
wrong and most of his followers returned
to their former churches. But some of
them refused to accept the error and
instead they sought to find meaning in
the failure. Part of this included the
belief that God was testing them in the
failed prophecy to see if they would
remain loyal. This is what the 7th Day
Adventist Church was born out of.
Initially, they thought the judgment of
Revelation 14:6 was in reference to the
judgment of God upon the wicked. Then
they did a complete 180 and said it was
about a judgment exclusively for the
righteous. The SDA church had to
accommodate for this. So, they changed
the meaning of the first angel's message
to something entirely different. Ellen
White further explains this shift in the
great controversy on page 424 where she
writes both the prophecy of Daniel 8:14
unto 2,300 days then shall the sanctuary
be cleansed and the first angel's
message fear God and give glory to him
for the hour of his judgment is come
pointed to Christ's ministration in the
most holy place to the investigative
judgment and not to the coming of Christ
in the redemption of his people and the
destruction of the wicked. The mistake
had not been in the reckoning of the
prophetic periods, but in the event to
take place at the end of the 2300 days.
So, here we see their application of
Revelation 14:6. For those that don't
know, the SDA church claims that Ellen
White was inspired no differently than
that of the biblical writers, and her
writings correct inaccurate
interpretations of scripture. So, what
she says goes here. She explains that
the hour of his judgment has come in
Revelation 14:6 is in reference to the
investigative judgment, not the judgment
of the wicked. This new theory was born
out of a supposed vision given to a man
named Hyram Edson who claimed to be
shown that they weren't wrong about the
date but the event and the location.
Jesus wasn't returning to the earth in
1844. He was actually moving from the
holy place of the heavenly sanctuary to
the most holy place for the first time
to begin the next phase of heavenly
atonement. With this doctrine came the
idea that the atonement wasn't completed
at the cross but rather happens in
heaven. Atonement wasn't even made on
the cross. Only the atoning sacrifice
took place there. They do not teach and
believe that the blood of Christ on
Calvary canceled any sin, but rather
your sins will stand on record in the
books in the heavenly sanctuary for
Jesus to investigate and see if you are
found worthy of having the benefits of
his atoning sacrifice applied to your
account. The first phase of this
atonement is called the cleansing of the
sanctuary. It involves a pre-advent
investigation and judging of professed
believers to determine whose sins will
be removed from the sanctuary. Christ
supposedly began this judgment in 1844,
beginning with Adam and Eve and
progressing down through the ages. He
judges all of the dead believers. At
some point, no one knows when, Christ
will begin judging believers who are
alive. During this investigation, he
either blotss out the sins of the
believer or he removes the name of the
believer from the book of life. Ellen
expounds on this in the great
controversy on pages 479 and 80 where
she writes, "Attended by heavenly
angels, our great high priest enters the
holy of holies and there appears in the
presence of God to engage in the last
acts of his ministration in behalf of
man to perform the work of investigative
judgment and to make an atonement for
all who are shown to be entitled to its
benefits. In the typical service, only
those who had come before God with
confession and repentance and whose sins
through the blood of the sin offering
were transferred to the sanctuary had a
part in the service of the day of
atonement. So in the great day of final
atonement and investigative judgment,
the only cases considered are those of
the professed people of God. The
judgment of the wicked is a distinct and
separate work and takes place at a later
period followed by a ripping sound of 1
Peter 4 right out of context. So in this
system, whenever a professing believer
commits a sin and asks forgiveness from
God, that sin is transferred into the
most holy place of the heavenly
sanctuary where it remains in the
sanctuary until the investigative
judgment is complete. At the end of
time, all of the sins of those who are
found worthy and pass the investigation.
Their sins are transferred from the
sanctuary onto the scapegoat, who is
Satan. He then suffers the final
punishment for his sins and all the sins
of the righteous. So that begs the
question, how does one pass this
judgment? In Christ in his sanctuary,
page 175, Ellen White writes this.
The law of God is the standard by which
the characters in the lives of men will
be tested in the judgment. Says the wise
man, "Fear God and keep his
commandments, for this is the whole duty
of man. For God shall bring every work
into judgment." Ecclesiastes 12:13-4.
The Apostle James admonishes his
brethren. So speak ye and so do as they
that shall be judged by the law of
liberty. James 2:12. So, you're probably
starting to see her wild out of context
proof texting. This is typically how
she'd weave together what's supposed to
be the biblical support for this theory.
But nevertheless, the standard to pass
this judgment will be the Ten
Commandments and how well you measure
up. If there are any sins unconfessed or
forgotten on the books, those will
remain on your record and you won't
pass. This is because Jesus will
eventually after this investigation be
in the heavenly courtroom with Satan the
accuser and Jesus will have to have
clean books to be able to show he's
right and just in saving those that he
advocates for silencing the accusations
of Satan. You can read more about this
in Christ in his sanctuary on page 178.
Expounding on this further, Ellen White
says this on page 486 of the Great
Controversy. And remember, this is only
being done for professing believers, not
unbelievers.
How solemn is the thought, day after
day, passing into eternity, bears its
burden of records for the books of
heaven. Words once spoken, deeds once
done, can never be recalled. Angels have
registered both the good and the evil.
The mightiest conqueror upon the earth
cannot call back the record of even a
single day. Our acts, our words, even
our most secret motives all have their
weight in deciding our destiny for will
or woe. Though they may be forgotten by
us, they will bear their testimony to
justify or condemn. So, we have this
judgment supposedly beginning in 1844 of
all professing believers back to Adam
and Eve where the Ten Commandments are
used as a standard to judge each
individual up against to see if they are
good enough to be found worthy of the
atoning benefits of Christ's sacrifice.
This entire process is considered part
of an ongoing atonement. If one single
sin remains on your record, either
unconfessed or forgotten, you will be
blotted out of the book of life. It will
be capped off by the transference of sin
onto Satan, who like I said, they
believe is the scapegoat that expedates
sin. To top it off, Ellen White insisted
that it was necessary for this doctrine
to be understood and believed or it
would be impossible for someone to
exercise the faith necessary to be saved
in Christ in a sanctuary. On page 185,
she writes this. Those who would share
the benefits of the Savior's mediation
should permit nothing to interfere with
their duty to perfect holiness in the
fear of God. The precious hours instead
of being given to pleasure to display or
to gain seeking should be devoted to an
earnest prayerful study of the word of
truth. The subject of the sanctuary and
the investigative judgment should be
clearly understood by the people of God.
All need a knowledge for themselves of
the position and work of their great
high priest. Otherwise, it will be
impossible for them to exercise the
faith which is essential at this time or
to occupy the position which God designs
them to fill. Every individual has a
soul to save or to lose. Each has a case
pending at the bar of God. each must
meet the great judge face to face. So,
the elephant in the room is any of this
found in Revelation 14, an investigation
into professed believers in a
courtroomlike manner to see who is and
isn't worthy of Christ's atoning
benefits. The early Millerites
understood this judgment in this chapter
to be referring to the wicked. It was
only after 1844 that this pivoted to
being exclusively about professed
believers. The judgment of God upon the
wicked is clearly the focal point of the
whole chapter. Since the wrath of God
was not poured out in 1844, how could
they continue to claim that the first
angel's message had been fulfilled when
the judgment upon the wicked didn't
happen? To skirt around this, they
formulated a theory that the judgment
referred to is an investigative judgment
that took place in heaven and not on
earth. And that this judgment rather
than being an execution of justice upon
the wicked entails a courtroom procedure
where God is investigating the fate of
every soul that makes a profession of
faith. They adopted this idea because it
allowed them to have a judgment
beginning in 1844 while simultaneously
allowing them to continue claiming the
first two messages had already sounded.
No one who sits down with their Bible
and reads this chapter would ever come
close to this conclusion. Which is why
no one before the 7th Day Adventist did.
Just look at some of the key verses
regarding judgment and wrath in this
chapter and you ask yourself if this
sounds like a courtroomlike judgment of
professing Christians taking place.
Verse 10, drink of the wine of God's
wrath, poured full strength into the cup
of his anger, will be tormented with
fire and sulfur. Verse 11, smoke of
their torment goes up forever. Verse 19,
the great wine press of the wrath of
God. Verse 20, the wine press was
trotten outside the city. Blood flowed
from the wine press. No, this has
nothing to do with the righteous being
investigated by God. Regardless of your
esqueological position, this is clearly
a judgment upon the wicked and is yet
another proof that the first and second
angel's messages were not fulfilled in
1844 like Ellen White and the SDA church
claim. But more importantly, folks, this
is not the gospel. It is a convoluted
mess that completely distorts the clear,
simple biblical gospel all in an attempt
to salvage a failed prophecy from the
19th century. This is only the first of
these angels, and this was really only a
scratching of the surface on the
subject. Sometime down the road, I'll be
doing a multi-part series focused
strictly on walking you through all
seven steps of the sanctuary, which the
investigative judgment is really a part
of. But as you can see, this is a
different gospel. Adventists, if you are
caught up in this mess, we are praying
for you. We do not hate you and many of
us were where you are currently. This is
a false gospel and it isn't the actual
good news of Jesus Christ. Shoot me an
email. I'd be happy to talk with you
more about this. Answering
Adventism@gmail.com.
If you enjoyed today's video or found it
helpful, hit that like button,
subscribe, and ring the notification
bell so you can be notified when part
three is uploaded. I'll see you guys
next time. God bless.
[Applause]
[Music]